There is an extremely disturbing report in
the Washington Post, which confirms actually
exactly
probably what we would expect from Donald
Trump, which is that Donald Trump told officials
he would pardon them if they break the law
in order to start building that dumb, stupid
border wall that he has completely failed
to make any progress on.
Now, you might've forgotten about this because
Donald Trump lies so much and he promises
so much that he's never going to do that.
Donald Trump promised his supporters that
he would have by election day of 2020 built
at least 500 miles of that fence or border
wall.
It's not going well because nothing is happening.
There's been about 60 miles of border wall
replaced that was old and needed to be replaced.
No new wall has been built, so Donald Trump
now in an act of pre-election desperation,
I guess we would call it, is directing people
to break the law to make at least some of
the wall happen and he is reportedly dangling
pardons in front of people in advance for
crimes that they would have to commit in order
to make it happen.
This includes seizing private land for the
wall.
This includes English, ignoring environmental
rules.
It includes fast tracking, billions of dollars
in construction contracts that have not gone
through the actual approval process and the
way that multiple officials officials told
it to the Washington Post.
Trump calls people into meetings and he tells
them what they want.
He says, start doing it, do what you need
to do and build this damn wall, and people
say, you know, Mr President, we can't just
start doing that.
Some of what you're suggesting is illegal.
Some of it is political, politically impossible.
We just really can't do it and Trump says,
start doing it and if there are crimes, I
will pardon people quote, don't worry, I'll
pardon you.
He has told officials about just starting
to build the wall.
Once again, the White House was asked for
comment.
They do not deny it.
Later.
Trump calls it fake news, which is a denial
that is worth absolutely nothing.
The most important thing is the White House
asked to comment and they say, oh, it was
just a joke.
They don't deny that it was said.
Now I know that because we're also desensitized
to the scofflaw nature of this presidency.
I need to be explicit here.
This would be impeachable.
This is depending on who you talk to, conspiracy
to obstruct justice on a large scale.
Uh, this is something that the Trump ist right
will defend by saying they all do it.
Look at Obama.
He ate fancy mustard and wore a tan suit.
And on another day, uh, it's every single
day.
It's another absolutely insane headline that
would have seemed unbelievable before the
Trump era.
And now it doesn't even get the attention
that it should because we have been so desensitized
and the constant endless scandal has been
so normalized that it barely makes a blip.
It's getting some attention, but it's not
getting nearly the attention that it deserves.
Now, one thing that we're learning is that
front and center, this administration has
shown us there is way too much gray area about
what is legal for a president to do a lot
of these academic legal questions about what
are the limits of executive power?
Can a sitting president be indicted or not,
uh, does anything a president, uh, um, uh,
does any action a president takes, become
legal by virtue of the president doing it?
The infamous if the president does it, it's
not illegal.
These, with some very rare exceptions like
Richard Nixon, which ultimately was not tested
because the guy resigned.
These were academic hypothetical's in the
Trump era.
These are real practical questions and what
is abundantly clear is there, it's just that
there's just too much gray area here.
We've not had presidents before, tried to,
uh, uh, flaunt the audacity to stretch the
limits of presidential authority and responsibility
this blatantly.
Now we do.
And it's clear that it needs to be dealt with
because he is flaunting his lawlessness on
the world stage and so far to almost no consequences
whatsoever.
This is an impeachable offense.
It's impeachable bribery.
Some would call it again, conspiracy to obstruct
justice by preemptively saying, commit crimes
and all pardon you.
Letting them know ahead of time.
This is a yet another one of these crises
and it's getting, you know, some, some news
coverage and it's going to be, uh, eclipsed
in the next six to 12 hours for sure.
By the next thing that happens, things need
to change and things need to change quickly
at all levels.
The Gray area of presidential authority needs
to be made less gray.
Donald Trump needs to be removed in November
of 2020.
This is only the beginning and yet it is not
stopping.
It's getting worse every single day.